hi
my name is alexa griffith yes my name
really is alexa but hopefully i want
echo today
and i'm presenting with my amazing tech
lead mike hurwitz who we call danger
we're both software engineers on the
data science infrastructure team at blue
core
and today we're going to talk about how
we use google cloud to serve tens of
thousands of personalized
recommendations
per second at blue core we have a saying
as simple as possible as powerful as
necessary this is one of our company
values
and we will keep this in mind as we
discuss the evolution of building our
robust recommendation service throughout
this talk
so gcp has enabled us to build a service
that has this value of being as simple
as possible and as powerful as necessary
in building the recommendation service
we're able to leverage the wide variety
of gcp
tools to store query and serve data
they all see some purpose but really
it's the breadth of their offerings that
make services like ours possible
while allowing us to maintain a low
operational overhead
so you might be wondering what is
bluecore
bluecore offers intelligent ecommerce
marketing as a service
we send you marketing emails that don't
suck and we aim to send you
better emails not more we're a company
that's around 7 years old we have around
250 employees
we serve hundreds of large retailers
including some you may have heard of
like nike and sephora
what makes us different is that we don't
send the same email to every person
almost all of our millions of emails
that we send every day are personalized
additionally we started providing
real-time recommendations on retailers
websites and we're going to refer to
this
as our on-site product
so let's discuss what even is a
recommendation
when we talk about a recommendation
we're talking about products that we
think
someone will like based on either a
product they've interacted with or
they may have a preference for given
their purchase and viewing history in
the past
essentially we map either an email or a
product id
to a list of recommended products for
example in these cases
two recipients of the same campaign
which is just the type of email send
left different items in their carts and
we call these abandoned cart emails
if we take a look at the email on the
left the person's left jeans in their
cart
it's possible that based on their past
purchasing and viewing history
we want to recommend to them a cami or a
t-shirt
on the other hand the in the right email
a person has left a collared shirt in
their cart
we may recommend other products similar
to the collar shirt as products the user
may also like
for example here we recommend other
types of collared shirts
but there are some things to consider
it's not just as easy as putting some
pictures in an email
and sending the email there are certain
things we need to take into account like
product exclusion rules which are
evaluated at run time
what a project exclusion rule could look
like is you say
in the email you don't want to show a
product that's on discount
or out of stock or maybe if you want to
show a product that's recently come back
into stock
since products update constantly it's
very important that we have an accurate
catalog
and don't show invalid products in the
email
this requirement definitely makes our
service a bit more interesting
and we'll talk about how we use our
product update listener to keep our
product catalog fresh
so marketers decided to send an email
and they create a campaign
a campaign has an audience and a
template a template has blocks which may
contain recommended products
the template is mixed with the audience
query that runs in bigquery and with
those we can generate the emails
products are then joined with the
audience in the query which means that
any decisions the template makes cannot
rely on anything that the query is
unaware of
generating audiences this way is very
flexible and we consider it to be a
competitive advantage
but applying recommendations at this
stage is very limiting
so you may be asking is this good enough
onsite was a new frontier for bluecore
that forced us to reevaluate our
architecture
latency became a primary driver not just
bandwidth
audience generation and personalization
are separate which means the templates
are limited to data appended to the rows
of the audience query we want to support
templates that are structurally dynamic
rather than just filling in blocks
and that means either making the
audience query aware of all of the
decisions that need to be made
which is pretty difficult or allowing
the template to pull the recommendations
it knows it needs at runtime on a per
email basis
a b testing is another example of a
personalized runtime decision that's
difficult to make in the database
previously we were copying some
recommendations into datastore to
support these use cases
and while datastore is great this is
really not what it was made for
and it got to be very expensive so we
had to build something new
pages on the web start to feel slow at
three to four hundred milliseconds
and recommendations is only part of the
on-site campaign process
there's also generating the template and
transiting all that data to and from the
browser
so we gave ourselves about 100
milliseconds to do all the work that we
needed to do on the recommendation side
we want to be able to serve about 50
million emails an hour
and if you do a little math that works
out to 13 000 emails a second
we targeted 20 000 emails a second
because we figured that would be enough
headroom
doing product filtering in the email
means that there must be enough products
returned
that the filters will be run across all
of them and they'll still be enough to
fill in the blocks
that means sending more products than
are actually required down into the
templating engine
we wanted to move those decisions up
into the recommendation service so that
we were only returning the products that
we needed
rather than returning too many or
potentially even worse too few
supporting recommendations via a b tests
is vital because frankly without testing
you can't improve
and we want to do all of this without
spending all of our money
so for the naive implementation we want
to change as little as possible
we know this probably won't be good
enough in the end but what it will do
is it will give us a good idea of what
areas we need to improve on
so if we want to change as little as
possible how would we do it
well we would choose to write a grpc
service to communicate with our
templating engine
and we want to go ahead and make use of
the data that we already have available
our recommendations data already lives
in bigquery along with our products data
that comes from datastore
so this would be the minimum we need for
our service to do runtime
personalization
the recommendation service makes up one
of three parts of personalization
with the other two being templating
which comes from datastore and the
audience
which is just all the people that
receive an email and is stored in
bigquery
the recommendation service runs in
kubernetes engine and is written in go
and the product's data lives in
datastore while the recommendations live
mainly in bigquery with some copied into
datastore
so now we've checked that as simple as
possible box but do we meet that as
powerful as necessary requirements
well when considering if our service
meets these requirements we're going to
evaluate the recommendations
and products components remember we now
have to consider
on-site or the recommendation on the
company's website
as part of the requirements bigquery is
great for bandwidth but now
latency is our problem we're failing to
meet our on-site latency requirements
even if we did export all of our
recommendations from bigquery to
datastore
we still might not hit our latency goals
and keep in mind for us using datasore
is expensive here
but we can't blame a hammer for being a
bad screwdriver we just need the right
tools
so first we're going to discuss how we
can liberate our recommendations
as i just mentioned bigquery cannot be
the source of recommendations at runtime
the latency is just
too high so we looked into bigtable
instead
why big table you may be asking well
caching's not a good option for us
because
the specific recommendation data for a
given recommendation type
email and namespace are often only read
once before they're invalidated in the
cache
and a cache miss would mean reading
directly from bigquery
which causes some latency or data sore
which is expensive
on the other hand they table latencies
around 15 to 20 milliseconds
and better the harder you hit it so if
we consolidate our data into bigtable we
can meet our latency's requirements
our recommendations including events and
our generated recommendations from our
data science models are still stored in
bigquery
additionally we started generating some
of our recommendations using dataproc
and these are stored in gcs we created a
service written in go that's a
kubernetes task running in airflow
just to migrate and consolidate our
recommendations data into bigtable
the gcs and bigquery api storage api
made loading data into bigtable fairly
easy with a small bigtable cluster of
just
three of three nodes we're able to load
read and write
150 to 200 000 rows per second
so now that we have our data into
bigtable let's talk a little bit about
how we deal with our data in bigtable
we have hundreds of namespaces but
bigtable has a thousand table quota
we can't have a per namespace table for
each of our recommendation models or
we're going to quickly reach that
thousand table quota limit
that's okay though they don't call it
medium table for a reason this is what
bigtable was made for
so instead we have a per table we have a
table per
recommendation model and our schema is
the key as the partner and id
which id could be like email and the
value is a list of product ids
so just to recap this is what we had
before
paying attention to the recommendations
coming from bigquery and datastore
which are now consolidated into bigtable
vr
via our bigquery to bigtable service and
we picked up literally
seconds of latency so now that we've
improved the recommendation component of
the service
are we good now are we meeting our
on-site latency requirements
well i mentioned previously on the
previous slide
that there are two areas where we can
improve our recommendation service
the recommendations portion and the
products now that we've improved
recommendations
we're still constantly fetching products
from data store causing it to burn a
hole in our wallets
additionally we're failing the on-site
latency requirements because of this too
so we measured data store latency from a
gke application written in python and
each of the products we fetch from
datastore are around two kilobytes per
entity
we found that the data store latencies
aren't great they're about 45
milliseconds to get started and then
an additional 4.2 milliseconds per key
so like i said not great but they aren't
totally disqualifying for our use of
datastore
using datastore didn't leave us a lot of
headroom so if datastore isn't going to
get us where we need to go
we need to find something else what we
need
is a latency smackdown
our objects are about 2 kilobytes and so
these are cacheable we found memory
store to be about two orders of
magnitude faster than datastore
fetching a single key out of datastore
costs about 50 milliseconds
but memory store for the same load costs
only 125
microseconds we're usually reading about
20 to 40 products per request so these
numbers are more realistic than you
might guess because memory stores
managed redis it was easy to find
clients that support all the features
that we need for performance
such as pipelining we need to avoid the
calls to datastore which means we need
to have a long ttl on our cache but
alexa already told us the products are
constantly changing
they're going in and out of stock prices
are changing images are changing
so we can't have a long ttl our product
ingest pipeline writes to datastore
as it always has but now it's also
notifying us of invalidation by pushing
product ids onto google cloud pub sub
we have a listener that reads those ids
from pub sub pulls the products from
datastore and writes them to our cache
you may be wondering why do we send ids
instead of just sending the product
bodies
well the product ingest is concurrent so
we can't know if any single update is
authoritative
by sending ids instead of bodies on pub
sub we can guarantee that the cache is
eventually consistent
rather than being potentially
inconsistent forever and we can have a
very long ttl
datastore natively returns protobufs and
those come out to about two kilobytes on
average now we could have come up with a
new
serialization format that does
everything that datastore's native
serialization format does
but there was really no reason to do
that because it's already doing it
but with about two kilobytes per product
and many many products we'd end up with
a huge cache which is both expensive and
slow
so how do we mitigate that the first
thing is that we don't
update products that aren't already in
the cash products get into the cash by
being used in a marketing product
which means that the only objects that
will be in the cache
are the objects that are actually being
sent out
so if a partner of ours happens to have
a catalog of a million products but
they're only sending out emails with a
thousand of those products
we only have to have a thousand in our
cash
the second thing we looked into was
compression but compressing small items
is hard
most compression algorithms learn as
they go
which means if you're compressing a book
the first page is going to compress
significantly worse than the 10th page
of the 100th page
and with only two kilobytes there really
isn't a lot of time to learn
by the time you get to the end of the
product and finally know how to compress
it
there's no more to compress so what did
we do
well first thing is that we downloaded
1858 products
from datastore for one of our partners
which came out to about 32 megabytes
and we then tried to compress them using
gzip and xz
and while the lcma compression of xz
is really too slow for runtime that's
kind of okay
because we're really just testing here
so we then found that we were unable to
do
better than two to one compression even
with a very slow xz
well that's not really good enough so
how good could it be
we took those same 1858 products and we
tarred them all together
effectively making one big book and
compressed again
and we found that gzip was able to do
better than five to one and xz was even
able to do better than eight to one
but we can't just tar these products at
runtime that doesn't make any sense
because we don't need all the products
we don't know which ones we need
so we needed something else fortunately
for us
z standard exists which allows you to
train its compression ahead of time
they call this dictionary compression
and that's exactly what we do
on a per partner basis we download a
sample of the products
compress them training the dictionary
and then we store those dictionaries
into datastore caching them in the
service as well
so anytime we read or write a product we
know exactly what dictionary to use
and the compression is fantastic as you
can see here
z standard with dictionary is better
than five to one
even on small two kilobyte courtroom
there are other high performance
and decompression algorithms such as
snappy and lz4
however those don't offer dictionary
compression which as we've seen is a big
factor
with such small bodies as a reminder
this is where we were before
and this is where we are now we have
products still stored in datastore as we
always have
but now they're being kept up to date in
a cache
with our product update listener which
is receiving invalidation messages over
google cloud pub sub
the recommendation service itself has a
small lru cache with a short ttl
just to keep the traffic to memory
stored down to a dull roar
and we think we're finally as powerful
as necessary
but how to be sure the only way is to
test it
and fortunately for us through the power
of gke this was
pretty straightforward we were able to
deploy our service
and the attacking client into google
kubernetes engine
and we could then scale both the service
and that client with a single command
the entire run including rescaling the
components was completely scripted
and hands off and how did we do well we
did pretty well
with 16 two core pods running the
service we were able to pull
between 56 and 60 kilohertz while still
staying within our latency budget
and we hit our target of 20 kilohertz
with just four pods
yes we are finally as powerful as
necessary
now that this code is out in production
well you know changes need to be made
and we need to live with it
one thing that we do a lot is when
changes are made we'll deploy a canary
into kubernetes
that allows us to validate that the new
code doesn't have a regression
in terms of correctness or performance
and then once that's proven we can scale
it up to the rest of our
pods logs are exported automatically
from gke into bigquery
and so we've got a one-stop shop for
when we need to look and see what
happened
and we're exporting all of our metrics
to datadog and because
this is a production service we've got
pagerduty to wake us up in the middle of
the night if something catastrophic
should happen
so what have we got well recommendations
are being written to bigquery and google
cloud storage
as they always have been but now they're
being copied into google cloud bigtable
products are stored in datastore again
as they always were but are now being
cached in memory store
and kept up to date using invalidation
triggered through google cloud pub sub
our clients hit us using either protobuf
over http 1.1
or grpc over http 2 and the whole thing
is deployed into google kubernetes
engine
i'd like to thank you all for listening
and thank you to google for giving us
the opportunity to speak to you today
you